[Music]
i've got one more stop to make before i
put my neck on the line to deliver an
authentic vietnamese menu for my
culinary mentor v
i'm feeling nervous but exciting and a
week is a very short
time to get up to speed with something
so magical
but where i connect is with the
ingredients because they're the hero
understanding them properly
will be a huge advantage going into a
challenge
[Music]
i'm heading off the beaten track into
the mountains near maichao
130 kilometers from hanoi
[Music]
this is rice paddy country and i'm here
to get my hands on vietnam's most
important ingredient and to learn the
rolls royce of rice dishes
to impressively these people one thing
you've got to do first off is cook their
rice perfectly
[Music]
today the village are celebrating the
end of the rice harvest with a feast
hello
how are you good good to see you
sau is the only person in the village
who speaks a bit of english
that was amazing honestly i felt like
steam mcqueen
now i know i'm a little bit late okay
and the harvest is finished yes i'm
sorry
come in time for the feast right yes
look at those little beauties there yes
hello hello
hello
this northern hill tribe not only pick
the rice they process it too but there
are no mod cons here
what's going on there that is
fascinating they cut the rice
from the beer they're taking all the
little rice grains off the
plant and then it's all swept into the
middle of the concrete yeah you know the
trash
this is incredible yeah not only that
i've never been on a bike this long in
my life
you can go towards france yeah
i'm sweating like a vietnamese pig
it's what all the ladies do in the
morning the harvest
yes
sometimes the men sometimes the men
if i'm going to look at risotto's in a
completely different way now
what's the old boy laughing at
hey big boy your turn next
in this 40 degrees heat i think i'd
better stop before i keel over
time to put all this rice to good use
and learn what they do with it
and what is this i'm making it's made by
rice
so
this is the rice and it's made with the
water and so it's pounded rice yes mixed
with water yes that's not sticky right
no yeah not sticky what is amazing for
me is the fact that we cook rice one or
two different ways in england
you guys have put a completely different
meaning on rice yes and she puts onions
and pork in the middle pork and the
mutton
pork and mushroom
incredible
thank you
for me to make these paper thin rice
cakes i'm going to need to apply a
delicate touch
that's a great start are you okay yeah
i'm fine the chair's [ __ ] sorry
how embarrassing hopefully i can impress
him with my culinary skills
i've lost half my mix okay
[Music]
now wait wait wait wait wait oh
that is what you call
sticking to
[ __ ] to a blanket
thank god i didn't grow up in vietnam
you know i've been used as a chef
here we go one more time
there's a fine art to this and i just
don't have it
no no no come come here i'm coming come
in come here
[ __ ]
i'm not gonna screw up anymore and you
know what i'm in danger of busting this
chair starting to collapse again
[Music]
very good
i'll buy some new stalls
[Music]
the entire village have gathered to
celebrate the end of the rice harvest
that is useful
that is a proper face
my failed attempt at rice cakes won't be
on offer
so i helped to serve up instead
right where do we start with this
fabulous feast look at this do you take
you take the rice and pass it along
right
and news of my botched rice paper making
has obviously done the rounds
uh what's your job my job
what do you think i do
you are a doctor a doctor
i'm a cook
good luck for next year's harvest
cheers
happy harvest
[Music]
i have been useless but sour's honored
my trip with a gift of rice from the
village
thank you
thank you
lovely that's beautiful
i will do the rice justice okay
they treat it like gold they show it so
much respect
they have a huge
uh technical ability to make rice
so fantastic it's
it's at a different level
it's been an amazing week but tomorrow
it's crunch time i'll be in hanoi to
prove to restauranteur v that i've
cracked vietnamese cuisine
so
lots of things bubbling and festering
away now in my mind and all i need
is to
disappear
somewhere quiet and just start
nailing down those issues
the next day i head south past ho chi
minh city and into the mekon delta
this fertile region is crisscrossed with
hundreds of waterways
[Music]
it's home to a floating food market
where i'm heading to learn a vietnamese
classic that's essential to my culinary
education
[Music]
inside this market is a lady who's a bit
of a legend she has a reputation for her
broth and if i'm going to get up to
speed
quickly within a week
about vietnamese cooking
the broth is the heartbeat
the broth queen mrs zehai is a veteran
she's been selling her suit for 40 years
and today are rolling up my sleeves to
work with her
good morning
is here to help too
so she's a master of broth she's the
master of broths so let's go check it
out man the only way to do it is to get
in there and do it yourself and we're
all going to fit on that boat
you are and i am as well it's a bit
rocky jesus you're right yep
seahawks boat was the equivalent of a
market cafe and a soup recipe is the
ultimate in fast food
and now she's going to teach me how to
make it
so the broth where did the original
recipe come from is it from her mom
she's from eating she eats on the street
she eats in these little stores and she
trains the palette to make it the best
that she can on this floating river here
yeah all right what's she putting out
there
yeah so that is the so we've got banana
blossom there bean sprout yeah and then
shredded uh water spinach stems yeah and
throw some vermicelli noodles behind you
yeah so here we just got some uh hot
water warm water just gonna be a lamp
okay so she cooks it very very quickly
now in vietnamese cuisine the clearer
with the broth the better right i mean
it looks like it doesn't have much
flavor but if you sip it and it's just
wow very complex
sea hai's trick is to put the dish
together in seconds to ensure it retains
its vietnamese crunch
thank you
wow that is delicious
and the fragrance are the herbs at the
end as well yes lovely coriander the
sweet basil texture balance of flavor
lightness that's vietnamese cuisine in
that shell there for you
there's no more time for me to practice
today i take mrs zehai's place serving
her regulars
she needs to sell 60 to break even 60
bowls yeah 80 balls to make some money
okay so roughly she'll make around
10.
incredible how much does that go for
less than a dollar less than a dollar so
we're looking at 50 pence christ should
we get to work
now what's amazing about vietnam is this
is how she advertises her dish i really
wish she sings it out so she's saying
both dishes but she sings in this
melodic tune it's quite beautiful
[Music]
that's what you have to do now
durian oh [ __ ] me half past seven in the
morning
singing for your breakfast
hotel bonfire i don't think they heard
you no jesus hotel
pompeo
60 portions a day a minute we're going
to do 80 today let's make it some money
[Music]
that was really good look at them
rushing
not one portion soldier 80s again
mrs zehai spent most of her life working
this patch but i could ruin her
reputation in just one morning hotel
bonfire oatmeal
bumper okay thank god for that customer
all right okay
boom girl coming down real all right
finally bean sprouts no no no uh-huh she
said bit more bit more noodles
huh it's incredible the way they work
there's ladies behind you she wants
jesus
unreal come on wake up
she said it's fantastic she's happy
she's happy
this is serious grafting beyond belief i
mean incredible
we haven't sold 20 portions yet and not
just the speed you've got to work at but
i'm being self-contained all into one
little spot here
cooking without moving
i've never known making suit to be so
difficult disease broth is a triumph and
i'd like to do it justice
hotel
[Music]
there we are thank you no chilli thank
you thank you
what do you think wrong g
no she's very quiet i think she's seeing
the customer i was gonna rush out
that's it yep how old are you someone's
called her over back to work yeah well
where am i
excuse me what about my brother
[Music]
this is hot hard work and i only managed
to sell a fraction of what xehai serves
up every day
please enjoy
thank you
telling i'm a chef
in the uk and i've never sat still
and had to cook in one place for so long
[Laughter]
she said do you think it's hard work uh
this yeah this is this is beyond hard
work
i've been to lots of vietnamese
restaurants in london yep and the broth
and the soup's absolutely fine but
nowhere near as delicious as this yes
you're an amazing lady
[Music]
a few days into my adventure and i've
got a brand new respect for vietnamese
food v was right mastering this cuisine
in a week is going to be a tall order
i'm nervous because i wasn't blase but i
i thought vietnamese food was similar to
thai but it's completely different
so
i think it's gonna be harder
to understand than any other country
i've ever visited
you